це вам горки погані за Вінницю
вогонь давай
А ось ще нова не випробувана в боях
машин
кожного своя як позивний так і назва
зварили установку
цей механізм нашої повертається
піднімається а вже самі труби це вже йде
військовий вони відвоювали їх у
загарбників за трофейли
Ось так
тут так
коли летить
снаряд
то це дуже
велике зусилля получається і
машину може перекинути просто це
збільшується її площа опирання
устойчивость точність стрільби такої
установки як у звичайного граду
дальність до 20 кілометрів Але у
міні-граду є безумовні переваги
мобільність і мало помітність він не
такий шумний як великі військові машини
може відстріляти до 6 снарядів і швидко
поїхати з позиції на підприємстві де
виготовили конструкцію кожен п'ятий
працівник нині у лавах ЗСУ це мотивує
тих хто в тилу працювати більше
підприємство кожної людини як директору
Важливо щоб мої люди вернулися бистріше
з перемогою живими не тільки моя всі І
що в нас заставив мир щоб наші люди діти
наші не страждали ті що страждають
Це вже другий міні-град виготовлений на
Вінницькому заводі з ним ще
працюватимуть електрики а пусковий
механізм поставлять самі військові коли
машина прибуде на фронт
на Вінницьких дорогах можна зустріти ще
й такий автомобіль це багі всюдихід для
військових машину збирають буквально з
нуля Вінницькі автомайстри ось це
наприклад наполовину готовий автомобіль
і оце тоже удаляємо зараз Ми займаємося
обшивкою закінчимо обшивку
віддаємось на
порошкову покраску
всі
все що буде відлягати покрасці потом
збираємо
Ну от це готова рама
зробив конструкцію цього
автомат усе збирають 3-4 майстри у
вільний від роботи час ця машина
[музика]
має спроможність на пересічній
місцевості рухатися з великою швидкістю
вона пристосована для цього вона
відносно легко
в неї потужна підвіска з великими ходами
відрізки
потужний мотор у нас мотор 200 сил
стоїть
дизельний такий багів отриму
є на них з поля бою двері знімаються
лобове скло відхиляється так з машини
можна везти розвідку чи вогонь це вже
далеко не Перша машина за проханнями
військових модель вдосконалювали Але
перед відправленням на фронт її
обов'язково обкатують
машина дійсно
[музика]
їде Юрій вчився на автоконструктора нині
займається ремонтом автівок усе життя
чоловік захоплювався багі займався
автокросом на таких машинах Нині ж хобі
перетворилося на обов’язок хочеш не
хочеш якщо можеш а я це можу я знаю що я
це я вчився на це діло все життя
займається тому якщо я це можу зробити
значить треба
бачити треба зробити
[оплески]
цей охайний гараж в селі за містом ще
одне підприємство Вінницького
оборонпрому його власник Володимир
колись виготовляв ворота і хвіртки тепер
робить станки для кулеметів
станина під крупнокаліберний кулемет
12,7
використовується вона як мобільна
багатолізу в нас є якби
розумієте
кацапського так що
багато їх знімають з техніки просто
А коли його зняти Там де він стоїть він
без нічого Він якби голий от тому що
тоді під нього треба щоб ним
користуватись оце все Володимир працює
над станками з 2016 року скільки їх
зробив уже збився з ліку але військові
завжди просять більше замість грошей
Володимир за роботу отримує дещо інше
душа
забирає
ранчами на кажній станіні писали ціну
А зараз я вже не знаю ми трохи збилися і
розцінки жіночі раньше брали
тільки за таку треба 10 років брати
оце вся ціна міні Гради баги станки усе
це організовує одна людина волонтер
Денис Романовський з 2015 року допомагає
військовим за 9 років роботи
в мене в контактах щось там приблизно 3
600 осіб дуже я половину геть не
пам'ятаю Не знаю але колись Вони
дзвонили записували ім'я батальйон там
ім'я бригада ім'я там ще місто і дуже
багато людей Денис зміг об’єднати
десятки людей своїх друзів місцевий
бізнес депутатів головний принцип його
майстри волонтерять у вільний від роботи
час аби мати змогу заробляти на життя
Денис домовляється з меценатами
відкриває збори в соцмережах закуповує
матеріали приганяє автомобілі з Європи і
сам їздить на фронт усе це попри те що
кілька років тому втратив зір через
вроджену глаукому ми можемо це зробити
тут і зараз а державі щоб це зробити
потрібно пройти півроку усіх
бюрократичних погоджень і так далі і
тому подібне ми сильні от всі разом от
своїм колективом якщо в мене якщо ми є в
такому колективі то Ну не обов'язково
бачити
Головне бажання робити тобто ну в голова
ж є руки ноги є там можу дзвонити
говорити щось в свій сегмент роботи там
збирати шукати завдяки дружині там
возити привозити так само їздити на
Донбас тобто є є наш колектив це ж не
роблю Я один чи хтось робив один як ну
ніхто на собі на одному Ні ну не замикає
В каждого в свій сектор робота в каждого
своя задача і воно Ось такий комплекс
роботи получається через те що ця
колективно чоловік ще не знає чим буде
займатися після війни міркує над тим аби
повернутися до юридичної справи Це його
освіта Утім поки і Денис і його друзі
прагнуть одного зробити усе аби Не
залишити війну у спадок дітям